Meet Theresa.
She's a CIO at a major insurance provider
and she's feeling stressed.
Her board wants her to
improve customer NPS,
reduce loss adjustment expenses,
and speed market responsiveness.
That's not possible
with her current claims processing system.
It's complex, it's manual, and it's slow.
She needs a resilient, scalable way
to react nimbly to market
demands and delight customers.
In other words, she
needs a modern approach
to transform her operations.
Her solution?
IBM Cloud Paks.
(upbeat music)
The AI-powered hybrid cloud software
is built on Red Hat OpenShift
and managed through one
intelligent control plane.
So it's quick and easy for Theresa
to start building, modernizing,
and managing applications
securely across any cloud with confidence.
Because IBM Cloud Paks are pre-certified
and pre-integrated,
Theresa can empower the
team she already has.
With the power of AI,
she can automate insurance claims,
improve the customer authorization
and claim process experience,
and reduce the cost of operations
all with no disruption,
no manual processes across the enterprise.
The result?
A happy board,
happy customers,
and a stress free Theresa.
Reinvent how you work,
and re-imagine the future
with IBM Cloud Paks.